you often talk about leadership
let's put the evils of hitler aside
the boldness of hitler in making some of
the strategic decisions he did
was considered by many military
historians quite brilliant
early in the war or insane
and brilliant stalin on the other hand i
think universally is seen as somebody
who is
terrible military strategist especially
early in the war
he did not see um all the possible
trajectories that the war could take
is there something you could say about
failure of leadership
stalin also the united kingdom
before churchill and also fdr on the
united states side
who basically
was trying to turn a blind eye to
everything that was happening over
over there with a perspective of
we just want to make we want to keep
america's interests
uh as the primary interest and
everything else let other countries work
out their problems
you know i think one of the things with
hitler was in the beginning of the war
he listened to
his advisors he listened to his generals
and
therefore they did pretty well with that
i think as the war went on
he believed that he was smarter than he
was
and made decisions that were bad
that cost him dearly
you know i mean case in point as
everyone knows going and attacking the
soviet union
while you're still fighting a war on the
other front is not not a good move
there's an example of yeah bad
leadership letting your ego get in the
way
believing that you can do things that
you that are beyond your capabilities
but you know as you mentioned in the
beginning with blitzkrieg
those were really dynamic and bold moves
and they worked
and that what does that do that fuels
your ego and makes you think that
you can win
you